[Müzik]
Çok
teşekkürler
teşekkürler Merhaba ben Tolgahan çoğulu
gitaristim Merhaba ben Sinan Ayyıldız
sazlica cisim burada olmak çok güzel
bugün size müzik anlayışımızın müzik
personelinizi ve müzik yolculuğumuzu
anlatmak için buradayız Bizim Hikayemiz
2014 yılında başladı Evet İstanbul
Teknik Üniversitesi'nde ikimiz orada
tanıştık ben doktoruma gitmiştim gitar
hocası olmuştum ve Sinan Doktor üstünde
yapmaktaydı son zamanların daydı günlük
muhabbetler imizde şey fark ettik bir
tane müzisyenler ikimize ayranı zazy caz
piyanisti Azize Mustafazade
bu müzisyenlerin bir aynı müziğini
ayrılması çok Ender rastlanır
bumerang adlı eserlerinde çok seviyoruz
Acaba gitarla sazla piyano üzerini
çalabilir miyiz diye düşünmeye başladık
Ve de altı aylık 11 Emek çok uzun sürdü
zor bu eserde 2015 yılında Bu eseri
video çekip paylaştık o
[Müzik]
bu
daha sonra Birbirimizi tanıdıkça Aslında
müzik anlayışımızı müzik felsefemizi
anlamaya başladık Eğer bize müzik
anlayışımızı bir şekle dökmemiz
isteseydiniz herhalde bu şekil tercih
ederdik ve Burada gördüğünüz gibi iç içe
geçmiş kimi zaman keseceğim kimi zaman
birbirinden ayrışan iki farklı biçimsiz
şekil var var aslında renkleri farklı
olması hangisinin nerede başlayıp nerede
bittiğini Anlamak mümkün değil çok fazla
Üstelik bu şekiller ne sazan Hadi git
arada tam anlamıyla benzemiyor Aslında
bizim çalgılarımız da biraz öyle E çünkü
biz bu çalgıları saz ve gitar a birtakım
modifikasyonlar yaparak
değiştirdik birbiriyle daha uyumlu hale
getirmek için bu modifikasyonları
yapmışız yapmışız diyorum Çünkü biz bunu
Aslında birbirimizi yıllar evvel
tanımadan önce yıllar evvel yaptık
birbirimizden bağımsız olarak
birbirimizden habersiz olarak yaptık
Evet ben de bir tane yaptığımız
anlatmaya çalışayım
gördüğünüz bir klasik gitar çoğumuzun
evinde vardır Ben 12 yaşında kendi
isteğimle çalmaya başladım 30 sene
geçmiş 37 hayatım bu Osmanlı geçiyor ve
gitar farklı kitap türleri çaldım
elektro gitar çaldım çaldım
bölümüne girdim Orada folklor kulübünde
Anadolu halk müziklerin de çalmaya
başladık Ve Ama bir sorun vardı bazı
şeyler oturuyordu bazı sesler oturuyordu
gitarla sonra bunun üzerine gittik ve de
bağlamada olan bazı sesler mikrofon
dediğimiz yarım sesten küçük sesler ve
gitarda piyanoda yoktu ya da tam burda
gördüğünüz gibi çok perde var bir Çok
ses var Bunlar yok Bunları olmayınca
kendi müziğinizi gitar Gibi piyano gibi
bakın Osmanlı'nın da çalıyorsunuz işler
eksik oluyor ve o eksik olan şey de
aslında Anadolu'nun ruhunu veren o küçük
ve mikrofonlar Ben bunun üzerine kafa
yormaya başladım Üstad Erkan Oğur bunun
70'lerde bir çözüm getirmiştir Buna
bütün perdeleri çıkartıp servisi
kitabını dünyaya tanıttı Ben de tabii ki
tarımı perdeleri çıkarttım ve de işte
peristor çalmaya başladım ancak etini
çok farklıydı Ben iliklerin kızı çok
seviyorum ya benim istediğim klasik
gitar klasik gitar gibi olsun öyle
kurmasına mikrofonlarda olsun kendimizin
de doğru bir şekilde çalayım bunun için
İstanbul Teknik Üniversitesi'nde doktora
yaparken büyük bir araştırmaya Girdim
gider tarihi araştırmasına girdim ve
kendi tasarımını yaptığım ayarında bir
mikrofona gider bir araştırma projesiydi
ütü destekledi ve danışmanı Prof şey var
beşli olduğuydu gitar ipimizi Ekrem
Ekrem özkarpat tabi gitara yaptı
[Müzik]
mi
Evet gitar tasarımların devam etti
oldum attığı 7 yaşında bir fikirle geldi
benim bitecek olan yaptı ve Kitabın
üstüne koydu Baba niye bunun önüne kalan
yapmıyorsun dedi ve buluşan Cennetle
yaptık ikide yapmışız ikide Ablası bu
fikri vermiş 2020'de bu gitar başarılı
oldu işte Amerika'da ödül kazandık yine
Mikrofonları alabiliyorduk bazı pembe
perdesiz yapabiliyor duk
denemelerin devam ettiği hâlâ yedi
senelik bi ar-ge sürecinden denemeye ama
sürecinden sonra Selçuk yeterli otomatik
okula gidelim fotokopinin yayınladık bu
gitarda işte hangi makamı çalmak
istiyorsanız düğmeye basıp artık
perdeler oynuyor size çalması ne kalıyor
Ama şu anda Bitmedi işte Sporcular
işlemeliyiz İnşallah bitiririz benim
çalgının öyküsü 2006 yılında başlıyor
2006'dan bu yana birçok çift saplı saz
yaptırdım bu çift saplı saz Tabii ki
benden önce de birçok icracı çift saplı
3 saplı sazla çalıyordu ki bunların en
bilinenleri nden bir tanesi özel
Gönlümün yarenidir ancak benim çaldığım
sazın bir farklı bir tarafı vardı Şöyle
ki o yıllarda Ben el ile çalma
geleneğiyle çok ilgileniyorum yani sazı
mızrapla değil ellerine çalışması ki
birçok kadın bir gelenektir ve hem yerel
icracıları hem Şehirli icracıları mercek
altına almış hepsini dinliyordum o
yıllarda bu teknik unutulmaya yüz
tutmuştu 70'lerde size 80'lerden sonra
tekrar popülerleşme başlamıştım evin
gençlik döneminde oldukça popüler bir
tekniktir Ve benim en büyük şansım da bu
tekniğin ve Aslında sazın gelmiş geç bu
acılarından Europa Allah'tan ders
alabilme şansına eriştim ve daha sonra
Bu teknikte kendimi ilerletme başladım
bu teknikle çalınan iki farklı enstrüman
vardı bir tanesi geleneksel olan üç
Çelik telli çalgı biri ise üç tane bam
telli daha kalın sesli roman alt
oklardan tutmayan bir çalgıdır ve ben bu
iki çalgıyı birleştirerek acaba sazın
ses sahasını genişletebilir miyim diye
düşündüm ki bunu yaparak bir buçuk
noktadan iki buçukta kadar çıkmış oldu
ama diğer bir amacım da aslında Ezgi
yerine acaba armonik gitar Gibi piyano
gibi çalabilir miyim ya da Ezgi çalarken
acaba Onu Armoni izleyebilir miyim aynı
anda çalabilir miyim deyip şükürden
çalışmalar yapmaya başladım farklı
ellerimle farklı klavyeleri çalarak
[Müzik]
bu
daha sonra bu çalgının pek çok
prototipini yaptırdım ve şimdi burada
birkaç tanesini Sadece burada
gösterebileceğim ve bu ilk yaptırdım
çalgıyı Aslan Türkmen usta tarafından
yapıldı Bunu ayakta çala biliyoruz Çünkü
arkası kesik olduğu ve askılı olduğu
için ayakta çalma imkanı da oldu aslında
satın geleneğinde olan bir şey bu
bu daha sonra elektro akustik bir
versiyonu Hacı attılar birlikte yaptık
Daha sonra Hacı Akpınar Hem bu İlginç
bir saat hem ön tarafında hem de arka
tarafında iki çalgı olan bir saz var
barındırıyor şu şekilde önünde iki çalgı
arkasında da iki çalgı var dolayı S4
çalgıyla Ben dünyanın heryerinde çok
rahat bir şekilde seyahat Edebilir hale
geldim ama usta dedi ki ben bir daha
asla böyle bir saz yapmam dedi
Daha sonra
Peki yöresine ekibine batıya geldi
çalınan elle çalınan iki saz İki telli
Cura İkitelli Üç telli bağlamayı
birleştiren bir sazı bunu Yusuf Aykurt
benim için yaptım ve daha sonra Burada
gördüğünüz daha profesyonel sahne için
bir o pislik saz yaptırdım Süleyman
Aslan yapımı ve en sonunda bu da ilginç
Erkan Ketenci nin muhteşem fikriyle
ikiye bölünebilen ikiye ayrılabilen çift
saplı sızı yaptırdım bu çünkü bu alt
tarafa farklı sazlar gelerek çok farklı
modüler bir çalgı elde etmiş olduk işte
biz Aslında bu iki çalgıyı böyle biraz
oynayarak ihtiyaçlarımıza göre bu
değiştirerek bir bir müzik çalışması
içinde Aslan zemin oluşturmuş olduk ve
bizim müzikal yolculuğumuz başladı e2015
yılından itibaren birçok konserimiz oldu
İspanya Fransa Portekiz Belçika
Avustralya gibi ülkelerde Türkiye'de
konserlerinde olduğu 26 İstanbul Caz
Festivali'nde bir türlü destek ödülünü
kazandık dünyanın en büyük dünya müzik
festivali bowmax müzik Evet bu da 2021
yılında seçilen tek Türk bulduk ve
geçtiğimiz Ekim ayında Portekiz'in Porto
şehrinde
konserimiz oldu
bir tane konseri çok özel olduğu için
anlatmak istiyorum İspanya'da Sevilla
kentinde geçen Ekim ayında bir
konserimiz oldu Ben 18 yaşında 19 gen
işte Flamenko aşığım arkadaşlarım işte
paralar Sen bitirip İspanya'nın en ucuza
gitti ve Sevil'e gittik Sevilla frayman
doğduğu yer ve de İspanya'da tutarım
doğduğu yer her ne kadar önemli bir test
için orada da orada işte öğrenmeye
çalışıyorum ama tabii ki 23tl sonra hani
Sinan'la bir konser vereceğiz yani
aklımın ucundan geçmiyor beni hayal bile
etmiyordum biz bu konserde şey yaptık
konseri biletleri erken bitti onu bir
şaşırdık sonra
bizim sonuçta müziğimiz Birazdan
dinleyeceğiniz bir Anadolu halk
müziğinden alıyor enerjisini Ama bu
İspanyol çekici çok geçti yani bu enerji
geçince şeyi unutamıyorum bir şehirde
olduğu için sizinle paylaşmak istiyoruz
konser bitti seyirci ayakta işte şey
Flamenko ritimleriyle bize bize çağırdım
dalgalıydı
mi
Evet tabi bu kadar konser vermek olur da
bir albüm yapmak olmaz mı Biz bir albüm
çalışması da yaptık ve albümün kapağında
Az önce gördüğünüz o logoyu şekli
kullandık Elbette albümün adı da
İngilizce morphouse yani Türkçe anlamı
sınırları belli olmayan sınırsız
şekilsiz biçimsiz anlamına gelen bir
anlama geliyor
Ayrıca en başta Dinlediğiniz bumerang
isimleri Azize Mustafazade yolladık
Kendisi çok özgü dolu bir cevap verdim
biz çok mutlu olduk ve hatta bunun
yayınlama mıza İzin verdi ve böylece
bunu single olarak yayınlayabilirsiniz
ekşi
Ben annemi döneminde tüm müzisyenler
gibi bizde uzak kaldık sahnelerden biri
bu sene ama özel izinler olarak Bari bu
ipler çekmeye çalıştık biraz maceralı
oldu ama Eskişehir'de Ankara'dan
Allah'ın da bir işte Başarılı bir
şekilde bazı kayiplarimiz oldu o
[Müzik]
o o
abone ol